Bầu cao, bầu tráp môn đi trời công bố ngại là vấn chính,
nở toàn cầu đã trả mất 3 chăm bác bài phở bài nghiên tỷ đủ là Mỹ.
Tăng hơn 1 ngình tỷ đồ chỉ trong nửa đau năm nay, cũng trảm làm.
Muy nhân chính đến từ đồng đồ là Mỹ suy yếu gần mời phần chăm,
sau với dầu tình tệ chính, cùng với chính xe kỷ tệ nửa làm tại nhiều người nạn chú mơ lớn.
Đàn chú ý là Trung Quốc pháp Mỹ được anh về Nhật Bản.
Lần những cua ra khi nhận giá chỉ nợ tăng mạnh nhất.
Vậy thì lấy nợ sau với chứ đi bay,
các nè đa Trung Quốc, ở Đập Sếu và bà lần chứng kiến mất 3 gió sệ.
Chúng khi ai lên, Nhật Bản và Ngà Ui, vinh nhận xu hướng 3,
Puy môn nợ là này đu sò xanh bây giờ đoạn được cuối nắm anh in cùng chá mới.
Khi các biển pháp vẫn phó đại dịch COVID-19 đẩy nợ tăng cầu tăng đục biến.
Bây tay chính cứ tế cạnh báo,
các tỷ trường mới nổi sảy đối mặt áp lực lớn.
Thì về thành toàn gần bác in 2,5 ti đủ là Mỹ trái phy yếu,
và khoảng vệ đến 1, chúng mình còn lại của năng,
làm xác tăng dùi gió đại chính bình cầu.